moi dès que je dois aller quelque part
où quand on donne un rendez vous et un
truc qui est sûr c'est que je serai
toujours à l'air toujours en retard
ouais c'est vrai que j'ai toujours en
retard c'est super chiant et en plus
fait pas exprès et les gens à longueuil
mais si jamais j'ai toujours en retard
je me suis rendu compte que c'est à
cause d'un mec ça à cause du mec qui a
inventé la touche répéter dans 5 minutes
sur les réveils tu la connais cette
touche mais en plus elle sert à rien
cette touche sérieux tu as dormi pendant
huit heures tu n'as pas besoin de cinq
minutes en plus excuse moi j'ai pas
compris ce que tu vas me dire non ce que
je suis dingue
ah oui pour les bilingues cette touche
s'appelle snows as noz à tous chez nous
il ya une autre raison pour laquelle fut
souvent en retard c'est que à la seconde
où je dois partir j'ai toujours envie de
faire un truc mais que je ferais jamais
en temps normal allez c'est parti
mais ces courses à pied de table bancale
faut absolument que j'aurais pas
[Musique]
ok c'est bon j'vais elle est en plus
dans ces moments là je suis juste resté
parce que je vais partir elle sait que
ce retard tu vois et je me mets à faire
des trucs un peu chelou ce que j'ai bien
fermé la lumière de la salle de bain
[Musique]
moi j'arrive pas à partir zen sera
l'esprit libre tu vois j'ai forcément
besoin en stress est en panique pour y
aller moi en fait je crois que j'ai
besoin d'adrénaline
[Musique]
ya un truc que je comprends pas parce
que quand tu es en retard et que tu
arrives au rendez vous tu as couru
t'assure était en achetant peu plus tu
as tout donné
tu étais dans le stress la panique et
arrive devant le mec tu vois tout
écrouler tu dis ça y est je suis arrivé
ben le mec qui t'engueulent [ __ ] mais
à ce moment là tu mérites juste une
médaille quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le pire c'est au travail je me fais
toujours défoncé et vaut savoir que dans
le milieu du travail
t'as pas le droit d'être en retard sais
pas pourquoi mais quelques secondes
c'est pas possible dans la tête de ton
patron ça forcément non alors j'ai
essayé toutes les excuses du monde mais
est tombé ça marche jamais excusez moi
monsieur c'est la touche ce nous alors
que je sais pas c'était à marquer mais
les filles quand elle trouve une excuse
ça marche toujours déjà et deuxièmement
c'est quoi ces excuses nul je suis
vraiment désolé monsieur mais ce matin
j'étais pas très bien tu te sentais pas
très bien
ouais pas mal comme excuse ça ouais bon
qui ça marche allez on oublie tu peux
rentrer c'est génial ça pas très bien
alors comme les excuses ça meurt jamais
moi je pratique un truc c'est le samu
mensonges parce que tu connais c'est que
à la fois tu meurs pas vraiment bien
même temps tu abuses un peu quand même
par exemple tu es super en retard au
rendez-vous et à la seconde tu poses ton
premier pied dehors tu envoies un
message de mecs qui t'attend j'arrive
chirurgien ça s'appelle un semis lyon
songe bécassine hockey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya des gens qui croient que quand tu
es en retard qui fait ça exprès pour te
la raconter tu vois parce que c'est un
bon call est ou non c'est pas cool
excuse-moi sonné je suis un peu en
retard je suis complètement chez père
j'ai pas regardé heures d'ailleurs je
sais pas lire leur allant des virées tu
te casses
non en fait je suis fâché père je suis
pas super j'ai rigolé tu es viré tu te
barres maintenant et je fais la forme de
pistolet ok bon maintenant on s'en va
maintenant que je suis devenu un adulte
j'ai enfin compris que en fait pour être
à l'heure ce pas compliqué ça me manque
juste part seul truc ça demande du
courage
[Musique]
j'ai vu que vous étiez plus de 30000 sur
la page facebook romane fait les vidéos
et qu'on se dit peut-être que ça
pourrait remplir un stade de foot et qui
auront un match